that is more than just a jacket that is
that is a historical art piece that i
purchased you sound like someone who
buys nfts no no no no
no you can't that is not just a gif of
young cat it is a historical art piece
you can't right click save that jacket
you can right right-click save and nft
that doesn't that doesn't apply this
also doesn't ruin the environment
um
this is a this is a historical piece in
10 years this will be a monumentous
jacket that i will make sure everybody
remembers single-handedly
this is this is a piece of meme history
this is a piece of meme history i don't
know man it's like stained and ripped
second hand right yeah i'll take which
is 360.
next time i go to the gym i'll see it
i'll see you guys get some japanese
grade
it's been robbed once had a little
scuffs here and there adds to the
character of the piece so
i you know i that to me is not a jacket
it is it is an encapsulation of our time
and and meme history has everyone
screenshotted this for poorly aged
things
but now no that is this is meme history
if there was other memes where i could
buy a physical thing i would buy it as
well what's a meme do you think that is
historical then that that that is
already historical yeah harambe
no no no harambe his sister no
is historical no way that's a meme that
is is if you're a mima you know harambe
yeah but that's that's the same thing as
like [ __ ] that doesn't make it
historical it's historical
just because you know it
is historical
like there was so little memes at that
time that every meme is historical yeah
because like back back then you there
would be like 10 memes in the entire
[ __ ] year these nuts these knots is a
milestone of uh comedy and memes yeah
unfortunately there's nothing like
physical you can buy for these
these nuts is an idea man it's a concept
it can't be owned by the people
it belongs to the people well the trip
can't be owned by a single person
the drip jacket the drip jacket belongs
to goku first and foremost and then me
second nobody else
can a meme really be owned though can it
can it be owned connor you could
participate in them
i'm fueling the i'm fueling the meme
economy
the meme economy if that jacket wasn't a
meme i wouldn't buy it
i don't think anyone
i don't know how much it was at retail
it might have been four hundred dollars
i think that meme's gonna be around in
two years
if it is and it's
like it's that that has staying power as
a meme yeah right because to be fair
it is like the drip goku meme has
weirdly lasted a long time
yeah because it pops up a lot yeah i
feel it's because you can fit it into
anything right yeah because it because
drip is last it goes hand in hand with
the drip if it drips around goku drip is
around yeah like what means because he
is the embodiment of the word drip yeah
like what memes have prevailed for like
the past two years has there been has
there been any meaning they probably had
these nuts has lasted like a very long
time because these this guy which is
well cuz everyone died these knots is
literally don't even i don't even count
decent that doesn't mean but it's gotten
so popular it's just like it's just the
thing you say it gets more popular like
every every month
it's like minecraft it died off and now
it's laughing like it's like having a
resurgence man it's just
minecraft music minecraft song who's
this who's that guy who sings minecraft
songs really badly
what there's a guy who sings like i know
minecraft parodies something he sings
really amazing minecraft parody songs
with a [ __ ] mic
it's amazing that sounds funny is that
the same guy who made the fortnight song
no chug chug with you yeah yeah that
didn't last long that that lasted like
two months remember that yeah i remember
that yeah
yeah
oh only because of the nfts right yeah
well nyan gets history just because at
that time it was inescapable it was
inescapable and there wasn't anything to
compete with it you if nan if nyan came
out like today people would forget it in
like a millisecond like yeah we should
do a three by three of memes we should
we should
i don't even think harambe was like that
funny though no it wasn't funny but it
was it was just around for a while and
it came back a lot did it yeah i feel
like
i can't
i'm googling most popular memes of all
time most popular i'm trying to i'm
trying to remember like funny harambe
memes troll face
well i guess so that was like the
beginning but now that's just like
cringe that's boy
i love that boy dude
is it weird that you think of troll face
and you you feel like a boomer you think
of that boy you definitely feel like a
millennial yeah
that's that's like a generational meme
gap but they're still both like still
cringe now i don't know something about
that it was just like a funny image like
you couldn't use it in any memes the
only time i ever saw like a dad boy meme
that was actually funny was like someone
uh took like the movie poster for uh the
boy in the striped pajamas and just
called it that boy and striped pajamas
the only one that made me laugh
everything else is just [ __ ] stupid
it's like it's a frog on a unicycle i'm
going through all of these what about
rage comics is that a meme yeah that is
that i mean that's the ogs right yeah
but like the troll face and all that
yeah
forever alone is pretty iconic
420 69 all that stuff that's is that a
meme i think so
4 20 is a meme like straight up i guess
and 420 is
somehow prevailed even though it's like
not that funny
it's kind of like just like a public
holiday right now it's the closest we're
gonna get to a meme public holiday right
the one day we come together and
celebrate
mean days april the 20th
i'm going through all of these do you
think like our kids are still going to
be saying 4 20
oh god probably
i hope not
i'd probably probably gonna find a
cringe right hey dad
shut up son
you did not know the meaning behind that
word but i feel i feel like sometimes
meme come memes come back around and
become funny again right because i've
you know with ancient with the ancient
memes twitter account i've i've found
rage comics funny again for like
it's it's like ironically funny now yeah
right rick rolling
that's a classic
the most classic and unexpected no not
unexpected it's always expected it's the
most long-lasting prevalent meme yeah
and
this one's obvious but like pretty much
every [ __ ] spongebob screenshot
yeah if any show somehow spongebob has
the most memes it is a meme factor and
they're good yeah they're good they're
really good
like think of all the some of the
funniest meme screenshots like 50 of
them are from spongebob that's true
that's true this is insane he was ahead
of his time man bro spongebob was
spongebob invented me built different
man yeah i i guess in terms of the
long-lasting it's probably yeah 420 in
my mind spongebob and probably rick
rolling are some of the three most
powerful yeah
influential influential you can't own
them you can't own them you can't own
them belongs to nobody connor belongs
i'm gonna have to make drip goku stay
around for a long time single-handedly i
can get some like investment but like
okay if you try to sell this jacket in
like a year right it'd be worth more
right if the meme's still popular if the
meme's still popular i'm not going to
salad though
you're hodling man
diamond hands no i actually want to wear
it
why are we talking about the durability
of a meme i'm just saying like i you
know there are some memes that where i
like it's hard to gauge whether it will
stick around or not yeah yeah most of
them it's got 99 of them don't
like do you remember how quickly the
[ __ ] cake meme died
what kicked me wait everything is cake
you remember that
yeah yeah but everyone was like this is
the new hottest thing and three days
later it's like what cake no that
prevailed for like a while what do you
watch do you think you guys don't watch
lesson in meme culture do you no no no
basically talks about memes and like
every single day there's this new meme
that i've just never heard of and dies
like within a day because they're like
weird-ass [ __ ] but like can you even
call it a meme at that point because
like sometimes there's you know so like
sometimes there's a meme that which
lasts a day you know i i feel like if
for me yeah truly has staying power it's
just like a week is like the minimum
yeah what what's the line between a meme
i think you're confusing memes
on like there's levels of memes right
there's like the public public memes
where everyone is in the loop
yeah and then there's like
only internet only memes
where it's like only certain groups on
the internet do this meme what's what's
the meme name i i don't know what this
meme name is well i find it [ __ ]
hilarious it's the one where they take
stock pictures and make really shitty
jokes with it
no no no no like like like the one where
the boyfriend is looking behind no no no
not that one like like like i hide the
paid how hide the pain harold stuff like
that no no no no like they take they
take stock pictures and like for example
there's like a girl lying down and a guy
um and she says call me an ambulance and
the guy like the guy like neil's over
and he says you're an ambulance
i don't know why i find them so
hilarious but i don't know what the name
of that meme is because i want to find
more pictures and more memes in that
category
like the son and the dad are in the car
and it's like
oh we named your your sister after roses
because your mom loves roses he's like
oh what am i named after and he's like
oh you don't you wouldn't understand 420
blazer or something yeah yeah like that
my favorite one is the honey wake up
that's it that's a very popular yeah if
anyone knows the name of that meme
please tell me because i want to google
it and i want to find more i just call
those like stock photo memes yeah but
like stock photo memes are so like
so wide and varied and broad because
you've got like the guy looking back and
i don't count that you know yeah why not
no because it's it's you know for me
what i'm talking about is like a very
specific shitty joke that works because
you got shitty stock images with it have
you seen the meme have you seen the same
images in the same category you know
exactly what i'm talking about it's just
so hard to put like a [ __ ] word and a
name to it yeah i don't know what the
name is i don't know
you're gonna have to show me these yeah
all right junior p yeah i need to pee